madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
il y a un peu plus de 7 mois dans une
attaque illégale
brutal
meurtrière
la Russie a tenté d'envahir l'Ukraine
beaucoup alors pensaient que le pays ne
tiendrait pas et que la puissance russe
l'emporterait rapidement
cette mois plus tard les combats durent
toujours
l'Ukraine progresse et la Russie se
retranchent dans le cynisme la menace et
le chantage
mesdames et messieurs les députés cette
guerre n'est pas un n'est pas seulement
un conflit entre deux pays
c'est tout l'ordre mondial d'après
guerre qui est remis en cause
la Russie a menti à la phase du monde
violer les lois internationales et agit
aujourd'hui la menace suprême
l'Europe n'est plus une terre de paix et
les armes ils font à nouveau des morts
des blessés des déplacés
certaines nations montrent qu'elles sont
prêtes à tout dans leur quête de
puissance
et si nous laissons faire le nouvel
ordre mondial qui s'ouvrira sera celui
de la loi du plus fort
cette guerre c'est une lutte pour nos
valeurs
vendredi dernier Vladimir Poutine la
lui-même reconnu c'est notre modèle
démocratique qu'il attaque ce sont les
droits de l'homme qu'il remettent en
cause
Poutine n'accepte pas de voir la
démocratie s'imposait peu à peu à ses
frontières alors il veut intimider et
écraser ce qui aspire le message du
Kremlin est clair gare à ceux qui
voudraient s'émanciper de son joue gare
à tous ceux qui croient en autre chose
qu'a déjà venir russe
alors quand la liberté et la démocratie
sont sous les bombes nous n'avons pas le
droit de faiblir pas le droit de
louvoyer la France et l'Europe doivent
être au rendez-vous
cette guerre c'est une leçon de
solidarité
l'agression violente et délibérée d'un
état contre un autre en violation de
toutes les règles internationales et de
ses responsabilités particulières de
membres permanents du Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU et seul responsable de
cette guerre et de ses conséquences
mais dans notre réponse face à la Russie
nous devons être solidaires
solidaire des Ukrainiens qui risquent
leur vie pour leur liberté
solidaire car pour être fort pour être
efficace nous devons avancer unis avec
l'Europe avec tous ceux qui partagent
nos valeurs
le président de la République l'a dit ce
conflit engage notre responsabilité à
tous
c'est un membre de la famille européenne
qui est agressée ce sont nos valeurs qui
sont attaquées
c'est notre détermination face aux
nouvelles impérialisme russe qui est
éprouvé
ce conflit dure et durera ces
conséquences sont concrètes et
perceptibles dans toute l'Europe et dans
notre pays
aussi comme je m'y étais engagé je
reviens aujourd'hui devant vous 7 mois
après le premier débat sur la guerre en
Ukraine dans cette émission pour un
débat sur le fondement de l'article 50-1
de notre Constitution
mais avant toute chose je voulais avoir
un mot pour le peuple ukrainien
les Ukrainiens répondent à la source
depuis 7 mois il subisse les tirs les
bombes il y a des blessés des morts
certains ont tout perdu mais ils n'ont
jamais renoncé jamais baisser la tête
leur courage est exemplaire
leur résistance leur héroïsme même force
le respect avec le président Zelinski
avec le président zeninski avec le
Premier ministre Dennis chemial avec les
forces ukrainiennes le peuple ukrainien
combat pour sa liberté et je veux avec
vous le rendre hommage et devant vous
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur leur dire notre
indéfectible soutien
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
souhaite commencer par vous faire un
point sur la situation opérationnelle
l'agression russe était illégale sur le
plan du droit international et les
méthodes employées par la Russie sur le
terrain le sont également
chaque jour avec le plus grand sinistre
la Russie repousse les frontières de la
barbarie elle fait usage des armes 11
discernement en ciblant les civils en
visant des écoles des hôpitaux des
centres commerciaux des convois
humanitaires dans les territoires
occupés on assiste à des transferts
forcés de population y compris des
enfants
leur libération s'accompagne de la
découverte de nouvelles atrocités comme
un bout de chat en avril ou à isium plus
récemment
ces images nous indignent nous choque
nous révoltent
elle témoigne de la réalité des
opérations russes et de ce que risque le
peuple ukrainien ce sont autant de
violations des lois de la guerre autant
d'actes qui justifient d'agir autant de
monstruosités dont la Russie devra
répondre
on note par ailleurs sur le front la
présence de Wagner société de
mercenaires qui prend ses ordres
directement du Kremlin société qui
emploie aujourd'hui des criminels russes
pour venir combattre sur le front
société dont les méthodes sont bien
connues comme en témoignent ces
exactions documentées en République
centrafricaine et au Mali
enfin les frappes sur la centrale
nucléaire de sud-ukraine et l'occupation
militaire de la centrale de zapporiccia
par les Russes font courir des risques
inconsidérés à l'Ukraine à l'Europe et à
la Russie elle-même
nous sommes extrêmement préoccupés par
la situation asaporigia l'arrivée sur
place d'une mission de l'IA est une
première étape nous avons désormais des
informations en temps réel sur la
situation et le risque nucléaire
cependant l'information n'exclut pas le
danger et nous soutenons la proposition
du directeur général de l'auia d'arrêt
des tirs et de retraits du matériel
militaire de la zone notre objectif
c'est la démilitarisation
nous sommes déterminés à ce que les
crimes commis par la Russie soient
documentées jugés et puni c'est une
condition essentielle pour le retour
d'une paix durable
nous voulons y prendre part nous avons
décidé d'une contribution exceptionnelle
à la Cour pénale internationale nous
avons fait don d'un laboratoire ADN
mobile à l'Ukraine des experts de la
Gendarmerie nationale ont été dépêchés
sur place pour collecter des preuves
notre ambassade qui n'a jamais fermé
depuis le 24 février et pleinement
mobilisé pour faciliter ce travail
essentiel
au-delà des lignes de front la Russie
agit sur tous les champs
je pense aux cyberattaques je pense à la
multiplication des fausses informations
et au moment où nous parlons la Russie
brandit la menace d'utiliser toutes les
armes à sa disposition
n'ayons aucun doute la Russie est
susceptible d'aller plus loin dans l'île
d'égalité et dans l'escalade
mais malgré les méthodes inacceptables
de la Russie l'Ukraine tient bon
l'Ukraine est parvenue à arrêter la
Russie dans les homblastes de Donetsk et
de luance elle a entamé aussi une
contre-offensive qui montre des
résultats on compte plusieurs personnes
ukrainiennes dans les régions de querquy
et de Liman et des avancées plus lentes
mais notables au sud de la région de
Kerson
ces résultats militaires montrent que le
courage des forces ukrainiennes et la
livraison de matériel militaires
occidentaux produisent leurs effets sur
le terrain
en reprenant l'initiative sur le front
bousculant les Russes et provoquant le
repli les soldats ukrainiens ont
enregistré de véritables succès
militaires qui doivent maintenant être
consolidés
il ne fait aucun doute que le dispositif
russe est fragilisé
la mascarade des référendums truqués
menés dans certaines régions de l'est de
l'Ukraine montrent que la Russie se rend
compte de sa propre fragilité et cherche
à donner un vernis démocratique à son
offensive
le président de la République l'a
rappelé nous ne reconnaîtrons évidemment
pas les résultats de ses prétendus
référendum ni l'annexion illégale de
Vladimir Poutine ce n'est rien d'autre
qu'une nouvelle provocation
l'appel à la mobilisation partielle de
Vladimir Poutine est un double aveu de
faiblesse
d'une faiblesse militaire inattendue
mais aussi d'une faiblesse interne alors
que cette mobilisation entraîne des
contestations et des départs massifs
vers l'étranger
mais nous nous trompons pas il est bien
trop tôt pour espérer la fin des combats
la mobilisation russe apportera de
nouveaux soldats sur le front la Russie
est déterminée et prête à tout les
combats vont encore durer et l'issue du
conflit ne doit pas être militaire mais
bien diplomatique
mesdames et messieurs les députés en
attendant que les conditions d'une
sortie du conflit soit réunies nous
avons un devoir aider l'Ukraine autant
que nous pouvons sans rentrer en guerre
avec la Russie
dès le début du conflit en s'adressant
aux Français le président de la
République avait prévenu cette guerre
aura des conséquences durables des
conséquences de nous n'avons pas fini de
mesurer l'ampleur
pourtant avec nos voisins européens avec
les alliés nous n'avons pas hésité
laissez faire la Russie aurait été
accepté un ordre mondial brutalisé où
tous les moyens sont bons et toutes les
exactions possibles
ne rien faire aurait montré à la Russie
qu'elle pouvait aller plus loin encore
et prolonger sa volonté d'impérialisme
ne rien faire aurait été perçu comme un
blanc un blanc sain à toutes les nations
qui veulent affirmer leur puissance et
nous mettre devant le fait accompli
ne rien faire aurait planté les germes
de nouveaux conflits qui nous auraient
menacé plus directement encore
défendre nos valeurs ça n'est pas un
idéal romantique c'est prouvé que la
démocratie n'est pas faible c'est
défendre un modèle qui nous protège
c'est affirmé que nous croyons en un
monde de paix et de stabilité
alors depuis le début du conflit avec
les alliés et les autres nations
européennes nous avons multiplié les
livraisons de matériels militaires à
l'Ukraine nous l'assumons nous devons
donner à l'Ukraine les moyens de se
défendre face à l'invasion
dès la fin du mois de février notre pays
a donné des missiles antichard des
missiles entières des équipements de
protection et de l'armement légers aux
forces armées ukrainiennes dans un
second temps nous avons si nous avons
fourni des systèmes plus lourds et plus
complexes des véhicules légers des
blindés et surtout des systèmes
d'artillerie César avec leur munitions
nous continuons nous avons formé les
soldats ukrainiens et des sessions de
carburant sont actuellement en cours
nous continuons à agir en européen nous
soutenons le lancement d'une mission
d'assistance militaire de l'Union
européenne sa création a été actée cet
été et nous y contribuerons dès qu'elle
sera effective
au-delà de l'Ukraine nous agissons en
alliés fiable et crédible
dès les premiers jours du conflit à la
demande du Président de la République
nous avons renforcé notre dispositif sur
le flanc Est de l'OTAN dans le cadre des
missions de réassurance de l'Alliance
régulièrement nous avions de combat
surveillent et protègent l'espace aérien
de l'Est de l'Europe nous avons pris la
tête de la mission de l'OTAN en Roumanie
en tant que nation cadre et de la
Baltique à la mer Noire nous sommes
présents d'un bout à l'autre du flan est
la Russie pensait trouver le temps
faible et divisé elle a ressoudé
Moscou est désormais que les alliés sont
unis près et ce qui lui en coûterait si
elle prolongée ses volontés guerrières
notre soutien militaire n'est qu'un des
aspects de notre action
dès les premiers jours de la guerre avec
l'Union européenne nous avons donc nous
avons donc pris des sanctions fortes
là encore Vladimir Poutine pensait
diviser l'Europe elle a fait face et
montrer son unité et sa détermination
face à la crise
je dirais même plus bien malgré lui le
président Poutine a renforcé l'Europe
le premier paquet de sanctions a été
adopté en moins de 24 heures cette
paquets ont été adoptés jusqu'à présent
et le 8e est en cours de négociation
notre objectif est le même depuis le
début rendre le coup de la guerre
insupportable pour la Russie frapper
durement son économie pour l'empêcher de
financer son offensive
nous avons pris des sanctions massives
et de tous les ordres des sanctions
financières qui limitent les capacités
de financement de l'État russe et des
entreprises
des sanctions bancaires comme
l'exclusion de nombreuses banques russes
du système Swift des sanctions
commerciales avec des restrictions à
l'importation et à l'exportation des
sanctions contre la désinformation russe
en empêchant la diffusion de la chaîne
Rush chatouday et de l'agence Spoutnik
dans l'Union européenne des sanctions
politiques contre les dirigeants les
oligarques les propagandistes avec le
huitième paquet sur la table ce sont
près de 1300 personnes directement
touchées par des gels d'avoir ou des
interdictions de voyage en Europe
les Russes misaient sur notre peur et
notre division
l'Union européenne a montré qu'elle
était forte et savait réagir l'Europe
n'a pas reculé devant les décisions
courageuses je pense notamment à
l'embargo sur les importations de
charbon de pétrole brut et de produits
raffinés russes
et ces sanctions n'en déplaisent à ceux
qui massent que leur fascination pour
l'impérialisme russe par un prétendu
patriotisme elle fonctionne
l'économie russe c'est qu'on
considérablement rétracté avec une chute
de 6% de son PIB pour cette année
l'inflation russe a explosé et la Russie
a perdu l'accès à des matériels de haute
technologie nécessaire pour moderniser
le pays et assurer sa croissance
avec les prix élevés de l'énergie Moscou
tente pour l'instant de maintenir
l'illusion mais les faits sont là la
propagande russe ne doit pas nous berner
l'économie russe est à l'asphy par son
obstination Vladimir Poutine hypothèque
l'avenir de son pays il jette des
millions de citoyens russes dans la
pauvreté car c'est son peuple le premier
qui ressent l'effondrement de l'économie
russe hépatie de sa volonté guerrière
les sanctions continueront tant que
Poutine s'évertura dans la spirale du
conflit et de la confrontation
abandonnez les sanctions ce serait
abandonné l'Ukraine ce serait renoncé à
nos valeurs ce serait nous soumettre à
la Russie la France le patriotisme ça
n'est pas l'abandon ça n'est pas le
renoncement ce n'est pas la soumission
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
fournitures de matérielles militaire et
les sanctions sont les deux piliers de
notre soutien alukraine dans sa riposte
face à la Russie mais notre
accompagnement ne s'arrête pas là nous
aidons l'Ukraine par un soutien
humanitaire plus de 200 millions d'euros
ont été mobilisés et 2500 tonnes de
matériel livrés ce soutien se fait dans
tous les domaines il se déploie sur
place et dans les pays frontaliers il
est coordonné avec nos partenaires avec
les ONG et les organisations
internationales
ce soutien continue en ce moment même et
un quatrième convoi humanitaire a quitté
Marseille par bateau la semaine dernière
nous sommes organisés aussi pour
accueillir les réfugiés plus de 100 000
ukrainiens ont été accueillis et près de
19000 enfants ont été scolarisés cela
s'est fait rapidement
efficacement dignement
cela s'est fait une fois de plus grâce à
la réaction exemplaire de l'Europe
dès le 3 mars l'Union s'est accordée
pour que les réfugiés Ukrainiens
puissent bénéficier de la protection
temporaire c'est-à-dire de l'accueil de
l'accès à l'éducation à la santé à
l'emploi à l'hébergement
c'était une première c'est un acte
décisif et plus de 4 millions
d'Ukrainiens en bénéficient aujourd'hui
en Europe
je veux saluer ici toutes celles et ceux
qui participent à l'élan de solidarité
remarquable envers l'Ukraine depuis 7
mois je pense à nous ONG à nous
entreprises je veux rendre hommage aussi
et remercier toutes les collectivités
qui se mobilisent organise la solidarité
et permettent l'accueil et la
scolarisation des réfugiés Ukrainiens
leur engagement est précieux et
déterminant
je pense enfin à tous nos concitoyens
qui se sont engagés nous devons les
soutenir et je vous confirme la mise en
place à partir de fin novembre d'une
aide pour nos compatriotes qui
accueillent des déplacés Ukrainiens chez
eux
notre soutien à l'Ukraine est également
diplomatique
l'Ukraine fait pleinement partie de la
famille européenne
lors du Conseil européen de juin le
statut de pays candidat à l'adhésion lui
a été accordé à l'unanimité il s'agit
d'une décision historique mais que nous
avons jugé indispensable dans le
contexte de profond changement
géopolitique qui affecte notre continent
le chemin de l'adhésion est long
exigeant il n'y aura pas de procédure
accélérée ou de critères au rabais ce ne
serait dans l'intérêt de personnes ni de
l'Union européenne ni de l'Ukraine et
cette dernière le sait mais je veux
saluer ici l'action des autorités
ukrainiennes qui ont entamé malgré la
période la mise en œuvre des
recommandations de la Commission
sans préjudice de ce processus
d'adhésion la communauté politique
européenne proposée par le Président de
la République tiendra sa première
réunion ce jeudi à Prague
elle permettra à ses membres dont
l'Ukraine de renforcer leur encrage
européen et de bénéficier de coopération
concrète dans le domaine des
infrastructures de la sécurité de
l'énergie ou bien encore en matière de
mobilité
enfin soutenir l'Ukraine ces pensées sa
reconstruction
on évolue on évalue aujourd'hui après de
350 milliards d'euros les besoins du
pays pour sa reconstruction
c'est un défi colossal et un défi
collectif
la France il prendra sa part
à court terme nous nous sommes engagés à
concentrer nos efforts sur la
reconstruction de la région de tchernie
Yves dans le nord du pays
nous suivons en cela le mécanisme de
parrainage proposé par le président
Zelinski
les Européens sont engagés après la
conférence de Lugano cet été une
conférence sur la reconstruction sera
organisée le 25 octobre prochain en
Allemagne
pour notre part je vous annonce que nous
organiserons dans les prochains mois à
Paris une conférence économique avec les
autorités ukrainiennes pour mobiliser
les entreprises françaises
nous soutenons enfin les initiatives de
la Commission européenne pour
accompagner et organiser le financement
de la reconstruction de l'Ukraine
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
le savons tous les conséquences de la
guerre dépassent largement les
frontières de l'Ukraine
aussi depuis février le gouvernement
agit sans relâche pour limiter l'impact
du conflit sur notre pays
notre premier enjeu est énergétique
avec la reprise post-covide les prix de
l'énergie avec considérablement
considérablement augmenté avant même le
début de la guerre
le conflit et l'arrêt quasi totale des
livraisons de gaz russe vers l'Europe
ont entraîné des tensions
d'approvisionnement et une nouvelle
hausse des prix
et je veux ici rappeler les choses
fermement
l'inverse pas les rôles c'est la Russie
qui a lancé cette guerre c'est elle qui
nous pousse à agir c'est elle encore qui
choisit de faire du gaz un objet de
chantage
ces derniers jours des explosions ont
été constatées sur les gazeux ducs Nord
Stream 1 et 2
tout indique qu'un acte de sabotage
grave et irresponsable a été comme lui
comme il
je ne tirerai pas de conclusion ici une
enquête internationale indépendante doit
être conduite et nous répondrons avec
l'Union européenne de manière ferme et
unie à cette attaque sur des
infrastructures énergétiques européennes
quoi qu'il en soit nous sommes prêts à
affronter cet hiver nous avons anticipé
cette situation en amont nous avons
porté nos stocks de gaz au maximum au
niveau national comme européen nous
avons augmenté les capacités
d'importation de nos terminaux
métalliers nous avons diversifié notre
approvisionnement
cet été le président de la République a
annoncé un plan sobriété et si chacun
prend sa part nous traverserons les mois
à venir sans risque de coupure
nous y parviendrons aussi grâce à la
solidarité européenne nous livrerons du
gaz à nous partenaires qui nous
livreront de l'électricité en retour
arrêtez la solidarité serait prendre le
risque de manquer d'électricité
une fois de plus le simplisme et les
propos d'estrade nous mènent dans
l'impasse
[Applaudissements]
protéger les Français c'est aussi
limiter l'impact de l'inflation sur leur
pouvoir d'achat très tôt nous avons pris
des mesures extrêmement fortes les plus
pop les plus protectrices d'Europe
le bouclier tarifaire a bloquer les prix
du gaz et limiter la hausse des prix de
l'électricité
sans cela les priorités comme en
Belgique en Allemagne ou au Royaume-Uni
il y a deux semaines j'ai annoncé le
maintien du bouclier tarifaire à compter
de début 2023 les prix auraient dû être
multipliés par plus de 2 au lieu de ça
la hausse sera limitée à 15%. c'est une
économie moyenne de 175 euros par mois
pour les Français qui se chauffent au
gaz de 160 euros par mois pour ceux qui
utilisent l'électricité c'est une mesure
efficace elle s'accompagne d'un chèque
énergie exceptionnel de 100 ou 200 euros
pour 12 millions de foyers les plus
modestes c'est 40% des Français
nous devons aussi protéger toutes les
entreprises et les collectivités face à
la hausse des prix notamment ceux de
l'électricité nous avançons au niveau
européen pour traiter le problème à la
racine lors du Conseil énergie de
vendredi dernier nous avons progressé
vers la mise en œuvre d'un plafond du
prix du gaz et vers l'extension à toute
l'Europe du mécanisme
ibérique qui a permis de ramener les
prix de l'électricité à des niveaux 2 ou
3 fois plus faibles que dans le reste de
l'Europe en parallèle nous travaillons
pour protéger les entreprises et les
collectivités face à la flambée des prix
de l'énergie le gouvernement présentera
prochainement des dispositions à cet
effet
en complément nous continuons à
renforcer simplifier l'aide mise en
place pour les entreprises les plus en
difficulté notre objectif est de limiter
au maximum la baisse d'activité voir les
fermetures d'usine
mais au-delà des réponses d'urgence
cette guerre nous montre la nécessité de
conquérir rapidement notre souveraineté
énergétique et de sortir de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles nous y
parviendrons par une stratégie
ambitieuse autour du nucléaire et du
renouvelable nous aurons l'occasion d'en
discuter plus longuement à l'occasion du
débat sur notre politique énergétique
que j'ai proposé de tenir devant le
Parlement
protéger c'est aussi agir pour nos
agriculteurs et notre alimentation
l'Ukraine et la Russie sont parmi les
plus gros producteurs de céréales et
d'oléagineux la guerre a eu pour effet
de rompre certaines chaînes de
production et d'augmenter les prix des
céréales et des engrais dès le mois de
mars des mesures ont été prises avec
l'appui de l'Union européenne pour
protéger les agriculteurs et les
consommateurs une enveloppe de près de
500 millions d'euros d'aide a été
débloquée des mesures spécifiques ont
été prises au niveau européen comme au
niveau français pour les secteurs les
plus touchés je pense en particulier à
l'élevage par ailleurs une plus grande
part des aides directes de la PAC seront
versés en avance aux agriculteurs
nous agissons également en français et
en européen pour faciliter
l'acheminement des exportations
agricoles ukrainiennes avec l'aide de la
Commission européenne nous avons créé
des colis corridors de solidarité
notamment via la Roumanie grâce à cette
action 14 millions de tonnes de céréales
ukrainiennes ont pu être sortis du pays
et contrairement aux affirmations
mensongères de Moscou parmi les céréales
exportées vers l'Europe 70% ont ensuite
été envoyés vers l'Afrique ouvert l'Asie
là encore ce conflit nous montre
l'importance de bâtir une souveraineté
alimentaire française et européenne nous
y overons notamment grâce aux
investissements de France 2030 et elle a
future loi d'orientation et d'avenir
pour l'agriculture
[Applaudissements]
cette guerre enfin fait planer une
menace grave sur la sécurité alimentaire
de nombreux pays en développement une
crise alimentaire mondiale est possible
aussi le président de la République a
été à l'origine de l'initiative
internationale Pharm qui organise la
solidarité vis-à-vis des pays les plus
menacés
mesdames et messieurs les députés
protéger les Français c'est aussi tiré
tous les enseignements stratégiques de
cette crise ce conflit montre une fois
de plus l'importance du multilatéralisme
nous sommes forts quand nous avons sont
unis entre-européens entre liés entre
nations qui aspirent à la paix et à la
sécurité internationale
cette guerre a prouvé la nécessité de la
souveraineté et de l'autonomie
stratégique européenne
l'Union Européenne s'est construite
autour de l'idée de paix et de la
défense des valeurs l'État de droit le
plus réaliste les droits de l'homme
c'est ce modèle qui est attaqué par
Vladimir Poutine c'est ce modèle que
nous devons être en mesure de défendre
ensemble
ces derniers mois sous présidence
française du Conseil européen ont été
l'occasion d'avancer historique la
facilité européenne de paix a été a été
utilisée pour aider directement un pays
attaqué à se défendre c'est une
véritable révolution copernicienne pour
l'Europe
nous avons acté notre volonté de muscler
les investissements européens en matière
de défense avec l'adoption de la
boussole stratégique en mars dernier
nous sommes engagés collectivement lors
du sommet de Versailles de mars à lutter
contre nos dépendances stratégiques à
commencer par l'énergie
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus isolés
quand nous parlons de souveraineté
européenne c'est désormais une ambition
largement partagée dans l'Union
ce conflit a marqué le réveil
géopolitique de l'Europe nous savons
désormais qu'il nous faut peser pour
faire valoir nos valeurs et notre modèle
enfin la guerre justifie les choix que
nous avons réalisé lors de la précédente
loi de programmation militaire nous
devons maintenir des capacités
opérationnelles fortes être prêt à agir
dans tous les milieux et à faire face au
retour de la guerre de haute intensité
c'est l'objet même de la revue nationale
stratégique demandée par le Président de
la République et sur laquelle s'appuiera
la prochaine loi de programmation
militaire
cette revue stratégique vous sera
partagée mi-octobre et je souhaite que
le Parlement soit associé au travaux des
laboration de la LPM
mesdames et messieurs les députés cette
guerre dure mais elle aura un lendemain
dans ce monde l'Ukraine sera debout et
maîtresse de son territoire
la Russie aussi sera présente elle est
et reste une puissance majeure elle sera
toujours demain notre voisin nous ne
pouvons pas l'ignorer
l'avenir s'écrira autour d'une table de
négociation et non pas sur un champ de
bataille c'est pourquoi le président de
la République a choisi de maintenir des
échanges avec le président russe
c'est négociations devront se tenir en
permettant à l'Ukraine de faire
pleinement entendre sa voix c'est
pourquoi l'heure est au soutien de sa
contrefensive et nous appuierons
l'Ukraine jusqu'à ce que ces dirigeants
estiment le moment des négociations
venues
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce
débat ouvrent la nouvelle session
parlementaire cela s'imposait avec la
guerre en Ukraine beaucoup de nos
certitudes ont été ébranlés beaucoup
d'urgences se sont fait jour et beaucoup
de transitions doivent être accélérées
cette guerre nous a rappelé que la
démocratie est fragile et qu'il ne
fallait jamais cesser de la défendre
elle nous a prouvé une fois de plus que
l'unité et la solidarité européenne sont
des armes puissantes pour peser dans les
équilibres internationaux et protéger
nos concitoyens
elle a confirmé qu'il était urgent de
reconquérir notre souveraineté
énergétique industrielle alimentaire
alors je vous le dis nous ne faiblirons
pas ni face à l'agresseur russe ni pour
protéger les Français ni pour préparer
l'avenir de notre pays la guerre en
Ukraine va durer mais nous sommes prêts
la résistance du peuple ukrainien nous
oblige nous serons au rendez-vous nous
serons à la hauteur je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]